how the gun rest my name spirit bad and
I speak deodorant nice anyway we're
playing afraid of monsters I'm out of
health I'm out of flashlight I'm out of
penis and we're going into this room
that I don't even know what wait nope
okay
I'm scared by the sound of the doors
that's lovely anyone in here Oh snappish
new I don't want to go there oh come on
nipple guys everywhere look wonderful
guy to a nipple guy three nipple guy oh
this is not good I'm tied up please
ahh all right nipple guys I I don't even
know what to say to you let's just
please don't kill me oh it's coming
right for me oh [ __ ] me nipple guys
everywhere nipple guy taste my language
diandra nice day on rent nice [ __ ]
they're surrounded me out of that sober
look at them nipples I just wanted to
put deodorant all over all right fine
nipple guy I get it you're pissed off
but you know what I don't care
smack that all on the floor smack that
give me some more smack that til you get
so [ __ ] high remember okay it's time
to it's time to start doing [ __ ] it's
time to start doing [ __ ] right now it's
time to start [ __ ] big job you're
going down there uh robot oh tap out of
my mom let's go
that's Cola okay I have absolutely no
[ __ ] ham I'll do it
well that's great big my language ah
[ __ ] I don't know how to progress Ben
this this is bad you
not good maybe I'm just supposed to
[ __ ] run for it
holy [ __ ] the house maybe [ __ ] they
looks so awesome I just want to touch
your nipples they're like hey man touch
your body Faraday touch about please you
little [ __ ]
I was just about to ante ah okay 50 LM
into time all right that's cool
back off back off this is my house
[ __ ] yes don't you dare hello nipple
nipple nipple
he spoke my language y'all just gonna do
oh no stop it's new he just charged at
me god damn it what am I supposed to do
I'm just a man with an axe and I speak
da Brent nice all right
that hurt that hurt my feelings all
right when I see this alright let's
finish off the first guy where the boom
boom boom gotta get down boom gotta get
that boom boom anyone else boy oh not
the charger bring it [ __ ] this gun is
[ __ ] awesome you just got to be
careful with ammo see see what I'm
talking about
ah you little [ __ ] hope you're happy
all of you six out you know what that
means
I'm just gonna go ahead and cook some
[ __ ] bacon alright where's my axe no
that's not how you cook bacon [ __ ] me
give me back my shotgun
thank you what is this on the bed lovely
i odd we can finally escape to another
creepy castle lovely absolutely
fan-fucking-tastic at for ammo six
health to battery bring it [ __ ]
bring it wait
oh [ __ ] me come on OOP very go back up
please
goddamn I hate those they're so [ __ ]
bad ah I then even possible hit return
from the dead oh no did I actually say
they're no it's not no no no I thought
it was that is not fair
thanks knees ah ah
agnese axe knees I guess all of yours
magdi on ready is it oh it's dead
alright
oh I quick saved in a real bad spot oh
anyone else anyone else anyone as Brad
ah that's kidding I did some would sound
like someone just came all right now the
creepy house you know that means my butt
don't shoot your come at me holy [ __ ] ah
I'm out of ammo
completely ah what do we do maybe
there's a why do you keep following me
but this is we want I don't speak your
language dammit stop joking me I don't
understand yeah what do you want I will
chop you I will chop you like it oh
sorry I will chop you like I chop this
but you can't climb stairs what are you
gonna do haha and you can't go upstairs
what are you gonna do now huh you got
all your angry you're angry I don't care
speak my language alright that was
probably a fan I'm holy moly boli slowly
say hello to max you never said hi I'm
jihad in your pointed so prick ah
[ __ ] me to other ones really need you
come on fight me okay I'm just just
kidding don't fight me I'm sorry
okay we only care we can only speak one
language one language only
that's acts I can't even hit them eat it
yet yes ah this is nice like a fun way I
didn't say I'm stop dying please stop
not I can't even see him oh god you
[ __ ] she had way too much what you got
going out here come here - I was just
kidding I was just kidding I was just
kidding I was not kidding you fell for
my trick my I was just kidding - haha
you are not the first all right
it's still [ __ ] dark my flashlight
ain't worth [ __ ] I can literally see
zero stuff here and I don't know if I'm
walking ugh
ah there's here's a path lovely
absolutely fantastic now ah come on more
debt
what are you fail it but I uh sharp eyes
H my axe right up your alley
yes I'm freaking Emily at this game
polish [ __ ] anyone else anyone else
anyone I know it's fangirls how the heck
tree of whiteness how the heck am I
gonna do this
tell me please she's right there alright
just run for it it's the new plan run
from everyone a bureau Nadel nipple guys
run Frodo no there's a flashlight it's
not gonna help much though but whatever
all right what am I go what am I going
white am I going what am I gonna gotta
run I got my garlic is this even the
right all right fine girl come here
just chosen lab come here come here is
it no no she got angry you do not want
to mess with the fangirls and still
sorry
come on buddy snap pineapple like money
but just once
okay maybe twice okay twice is the
deadly number apparently I don't know
what to do about you please tell me it
is it's a present from your mother she
called me yesterday hell are you doing
so disgusting
I am deeply disappointed but here's my
axe aren't you dead yet
seriously you demon spawn and it could
be that's four that's five are you not
done it's impossible
alright maybe six okay same and then eat
it how are you not dead
please explain thank you thank you thank
you
alright that I know let's find more
really one to twist prior to the [ __ ]
that was not good all right oh no oh na
na fiving dis little boys were good but
no you have to be a little [ __ ] don't
you all your life I can see right
through you you've been a bet you're on
now let's watch for you by dial in time
yang
alright let's just run for it hi
everyone hi today I'm just gonna pick up
whatever I just [ __ ] picked up all
right keep running keep running like a
boss keep running like a boss keep
running like a boss keep running like a
basket browning like a boo keep running
like about hey thanks prime shooter hi
you don't know don't black me I don't
appreciate all right running like a bar
running like a mouse running I'm out
wrong oh my god how you feeling Bryant
ah he's blocking my walls not a Shh I
don't even know what - how much book ah
I have to action use him what never guy
not now
oh you're such an attention [ __ ] a
Shinji aren't you whatever okay nipple
guys I get it
you want to fight dumb strong get harder
better faster stronger that that I don't
kill me to put deodorant on your arms
honey come on
three times three times what the hell
are you doing three times I don't need
you I don't need you I don't need you
and you [ __ ] alright come here come
here come here
hi you think you're a scorpion okay here
are a scorpion good job you're looks
like it's gone you could be as
government come here buddy come here
come here oh now you see how close that
what you're nearly [ __ ] come in my
face alright latest rave skills slave
skills strafe skills hey about go yes
hi dodge that [ __ ] alone no again day
mam ajam yes alright let's just row row
row your boat gently down the stream if
you see your sperm shoot there don't
forget to scream alright what do we have
here oh isn't that lovely someone just
left a deagle at me that's just too kind
is it was you - your whiteness I thank
you I appreciate it I appreciate so much
all right I'm pretty sure I don't want
to go there yet
whereas we must investigate this house I
actually know we must not do it sure you
have wideness good day to you sir
all right I have a deagle barrooms mom
oh come on room is mom sick of your [ __ ]
I'm sick of your [ __ ] now I really is
unique
all right Rubens mom I want in the head
and she's eating it
yes oh no she's still alive he's dead
now Reubens mom you don't now Ruby mom
Oh No Reubens mama everywhere
[ __ ] me rooms mama everywhere I gotta
run to the toilet stapes kill strafe
skills strafe against faith kiss baby of
kid you Jake so [ __ ] close to the
toilet must make it this is toilet back
up back up all of you is no way [ __ ]
way in million years I'm gonna make this
this is just [ __ ] impossible room is
mom
finally knew where the [ __ ] she is this
is Robin's mom right in my face all
right it's des I don't even know what
that is
shotgun ammo or [ __ ] me I have zero
health how am I gonna do this against 20
million rumors mom edit edit all right
that was not bad
that was not bad just one more yes all
right
huh Oh dishes this what is it when I
picked them over something don't tell me
I have to ask knees her it's impossible
no no no you can taxi nice rumors mom no
sir no sir you can't all right for spot
ah [ __ ] me she [ __ ] me I didn't want
her to do it why do you keep
resurrecting no one likes Aria I just
needed one more just one more
Benjamin Akane
go back stabs she liked it she likes you
from behind all right let's use that as
our advantage
holy [ __ ] I made it this way all right
let's do this rosebud rosebud rubbish
Bob nervous Rob Rob Rob Rob gravity
drivers Bob revving forever right right
right
holy [ __ ] how did I make it hurry on
tree of ripeness honey I don't even
understand what's going bust up and down
please no more mile set please what what
did I do
didn't I open the gate or something Oh
wait a second why am I wasting my
passion didn't I click EU but this game
is so difficult you have no idea
well maybe you have an idea probably not
my word just why can I move what the
hell was that
fine share anyone out there hey lovely
isn't that cute alright hell of is good
no I was talking to Brad why don't you
never learn
all right one more [ __ ] you [ __ ] all of
you
[ __ ] I have to hell are you [ __ ]
kidding me I'm not gonna die I'm not
gonna die
I died are you happy okay he's happy but
that does not mean I'm not happy
okay I'm not happy okay not happy with
your performance seriously you could
since sitter and you can beg
chiropractor or whatever they're called
alright and the movements in here no
what is this oh this is [ __ ] all of
it is [ __ ] I ate [ __ ] for
breakfast no I don't but I could if I
wanted to my mom said you're allowed to
do it ro
Lucas back he is pissed cuz I'd kill his
mom three all three of them pity
be careful I know I'm gonna be careful
you're a plant you have note saying in
this charge [ __ ]
naw naw I left all right
dilated ever died epic battle of Rubin
well done that was it really good okay
whatever
anyone wanna fight where are they give
me a status report miss plant
I don't know pity there's about two in
the left room and one in the room to do
ass be careful Thank You mr. plantain
alright let's just hope he wasn't giving
us bad Intel
ah it's yo why don't you ever stop but
just as you want are you trying to tell
me something please
I'm trying to I'm on your side place
it's a plant what should I do I don't
know Harry I don't know
Oh should I end your suffering huh what
are you doing
don't leave period on me holy [ __ ] I
thought you were a man how is it
possible this is really confusing for me
alright fine I have to do your favor and
smash these your deodorant face at two
health now I'll be a [ __ ] happy this
room is just delighting oh you see that
[ __ ]
I saw a Reuben in the other room and
it's locked - that's Robin mad drama I
don't know what I just said but I said
something why did we go here
Reuben eat it eat it yeah
oh you shad you said because your mom
died and you die - I don't care this is
what your mom looks like probably I am
that's not good for me though cuz I
nothing okay but as I say go down or gr
now what what what did i do I didn't do
anything
gr down I didn't invent this I did not
demand this go down no sir I'm not gonna
go down a fight I'd go down mr. plan -
no snappy so you lied to me I'm sorry -
bond dad Savas know he was a go down no
matter who you should have given me
better in town and they'll [ __ ] it all
right to health to health bad
little [ __ ] mr. planned
what's a plan tell me what should I do
aah aah
god damn it I don't have any ammo left
okay why do we get we haven't had drugs
thanks baby Jesus all right huh what is
this they trying to tell me something
television what he's trying to tell me I
don't have any ammo in Aden you
this is charger and I hate those little
[ __ ] all right smash nice smash nice
well done sir
but I don't care what do we got what do
we got we have a shotgun there should be
something else here what's going on mr.
plant aah
they never communicate ever come on
something behind this I knew it what are
you doing taking a shower you don't even
have a [ __ ] arm or legs for that
matter or a penis for that third matter
all right I'm gonna end this episode
here like a favorite you enjoyed
subscribe to come abroad today and I'll
see you next episode
ha ha ha
[Music]
ah
I didn't say